tonight we continue our regulation
nation series with a look at how
president Trump's massive infrastructure
plan could result in significant cutting
of federal red tape correspondent Doug
mackelway tells us how that would work
the Bayonne Bridge is a symbol of what
ails us infrastructure in 2009 the first
environmental impact studies were
undertaken to raise this roadway to
allow tall ships to pass underneath but
the studies alone took five years and
generated 10,000 pages of environmental
assessments and another 10,000 pages of
permitting the project is not slated for
completion until 2019 we built the
Empire State Building in just one year
the Trump administration is trying to
cut through such red tape as it proposes
a 1.5 trillion dollar infrastructure
program the political will has not been
there because you've got to take on a
lot of lawyers a lot of environmental
groups but this president has shown that
he's not afraid of those fights four
days after his inauguration the
president signed a memorandum to begin
streamlining the White House side of
this study as its roadmap it found the
permitting process so cumbersome it
sometimes harms the environment by
delaying construction of quote America's
antiquated power grid for example waste
the equivalent of 200 coal burning power
plants or 150 billion dollars per year
in subsequent memoranda the White House
promised to establish a one agency one
decision structure for environmental
review shorten the lengthy environmental
review process to two years and
eliminate redundant provisions in
environmental law
environmentalists and their Washington
ally say it's a wrong approach I would
never argue for a slower permitting
process
but the way to make it faster is to fund
the agencies that already have the
charge of putting permits through the
system the Trump plan also gives more
power to the states who've learned they
need to make permitting easier to be
competitive the states in many ways have
loved the way they often move toward
things like one-stop shopping so-called
concierge services
even so Trump's infrastructure promises
will be hard to keep after he gave the
go-ahead to complete the Keystone XL
pipeline a year ago it remains
unfinished and environmentalists filed a
new lawsuit this week to block it right
Doug thank you